the coronation is so old that it is full
of the most quirky facts and I'm going
to bring some of them to you now
my favorite part of the coronation comes
when the king is being invested with the
two scepters the one in his right hand
is of kingly power the one in his left
is of kingly Mercy but before he gets
given the one of kingly power very
quietly is someone places a glove on his
right hand
to remind him to be gentle in the use of
power the most religious part of the
coronation is the anointing when the
king is Anointed with oil
but the most quirky part of the oil is
the story of the old oil that's been
replaced no longer does the king want to
use the old menu that went into creating
the oil which included musk which is
squeezed from the backside of a civet
cat Westminster Abbey was founded by the
Saxon King Edward the Confessor and it
became the coronation church that meant
that it would be designed and built
differently from any other
all churches of this size are built on
the shape of a cross
and most the top end is called the
chancel and they have a screen to cut it
off
but for a coronation church the screen
comes much further down so that where
the crossing itself takes place is a
huge open area that becomes the theater
of the coronation itself in fact this
will be the first coronation that is a
thousand years old because the first one
that took place was when an Archbishop
called Saint Dunstan put the crown upon
the head of Edgar the Peaceable in the
year 973 in bath
I'm governor of Edinburgh Castle and we
keep in the Fortress the stone of
Destiny or the stone of schoon
[Music]
during the late Queens Reign the stone
of Destiny was returned to Scotland
where it will forever be kept and
maintained
in the 13th century King Edward the
first of England removed it from
Scotland and brought it here to
Westminster Abbey
and he had built for it the chair that
we will see the king anointed in and
crowned him